it's a debt-free college our on the Dave
Ramsey show yes it can be done
we have callers calling in that have
recent college graduates are going to
tell us how they did it
we know Rachel knows Rachel Cruz my
daughter is with us co-author with me of
the number one New York Times
best-selling book smart money smart kids
we know there's five things you can do
if you do those five things it is
possible to go to school debt-free two
of them we've already covered we're
going to come back and make sure all
five are covered during this hour so
don't leave the meantime let's talk to
faith in Fort Hood Texas hi faith how
are you hi mom how are you I am better
than I deserve so when did you graduate
2008 2008 and you went to school
100% debt-free yes where'd you go to
school
Pensacola Christian College in Florida
okay and a four-year school yes sir in a
private school right face yeah yeah so
what'd you get your degree in accounting
Wow okay
and how long did it take you to get out
oh four years or you did four years and
four years yeah I did you're a unicorn
like a car like guys are debt free and
him for years so how did you do this
debt-free tell me about it
well my brother is nine years older than
me and when he was going to college my
parents made it very clear to the rest
of us in my family that they were not
going to be paying for our college so
even at you know nine years old I was
already thinking about that they did
however provide us with vehicle ticket
to work they said they were going to
help us earn our college money by giving
us a vehicle to eat lending us a vehicle
I guess you could say to to use and
oddly well show when you were not and
that's probably when you were 16 right
right but my dad owns his own business
and at 12 he allowed me to kind of start
doing some stuff to earn money here
there I started nannying at 14 I'm about
eight hours a week I was home-schooled
so I could kind of adjust my schooling
schedule to fit my heart schedule which
enabled me to work a lot of jobs that I
wouldn't have been able to otherwise
when I was 16 I started working at a
bank pretty much full-time
he around and during my school in the
evenings and was able to make very a lot
of savings not a lot of savings and so I
actually went into my freshman year of
college with 12,000 dollars in the bank
Wow in the school the school that I went
to all women board included was only at
the time about 6,500 a year so I really
had my first two years paid for by the
time I left and so my freshman year I
didn't work while I was at school I kind
of wanted to adjust to that schedule
first but then some sophomore year on I
worked while I was at school between 20
and 30 hours a week and then I'd come
home and I worked 50 to 60 hours a week
during the summer at the bank they
allowed me to do overtime which was a
huge blessing and then I babysit here
there worked for my dad still some
trying some extra money so I was
actually able to graduate with money in
savings instead of in debt which was my
goal but I was still I think a little
surprised that I was able to accomplish
it I'm not as hard as you worked you
worked like an animal girl I did how
hard was it for you to hardly hit the
wreck like an animal now the hard wasn't
for a job how hard was it for you to
find a job when you're not difficult at
all
I actually went to go work for a
ministry and the job kind of fell in my
lap and I was there for six years after
I graduated and then last summer I moved
to get married down to Texas and that
was a little bit more difficult because
I was so far removed from college people
you know employers were a little bit
hesitant but once I got in a job I was I
mean I moved up the ranks pay raises
everything really quick so it's I've
always been blessed with very well
paying good jobs with great employers
that's amazing so you're working 20 to
30 hours while going to school so what
you say so was that hard to keep up your
studies because that's what I hear a lot
of college students say and parents you
know we don't want our child to work
because their grades may slip right I
would say it was I probably sure would
more with time management when I wasn't
working because having having a shorter
time period where you're dead
- a little bit more foreboding yeah it
was easier to really like put my put my
head to it and get my homework done and
I actually I think had more free time or
I appreciated the free time I had more
than when I was a freshman and just kind
of oh my homework takes me an hour and I
have four hours tonight to do nothing so
totally yeah a lot of research shows
that students who work 19 hours a week
graduate with higher GPAs than students
who don't work at all just exactly like
you said it's the time management you're
forced right at a time okay this is what
I have to work and study in sort of
going back to the dorm and watching
reality TV and eating Doritos you don't
I mean just do whatever you want I mean
you have to have a schedule and that
puts so much you know Josh character
building in you to be able to structure
all of that's amazing right what was
your GPA I had a 4.0 actually ding well
there we go
I'm not shocked and what's your income
now my income now I'm working part-time
I'm making about $15 an hour doing
accounting work I've never I mean when I
read after I graduated in a ministry my
income was not very much at all but
thankfully I knew had to live on little
because that's what I kind of been
preparing for the whole time I was in
college you know I didn't go out to eat
a lot in college because I didn't I
didn't want to spend that money on that
because I wasn't sure I was going to
have enough to pay my bills yeah
excellent well I would hire her amazing
she's very employable I mean listen to
her not I mean the 4.0 is impressive not
nearly as impressive as that as the work
ethic and a degree that's marketable an
accounting degree I mean this this is
this is how you make successful children
people you just heard it this is amazing
absolutely awesome thank you faith Matt
is next matt is in Salt Lake City hey
Matt how are you I'm doing great how are
you Dave better than I deserve so what
year did you graduate so I graduated in
2005 from Weber State University in Utah
okay and what's your degree in Business
Administration
okay and how long it take you to get out
of school so I I did it in four and a
half years but I had to take a semester
off because after my first semester of
college I
got married oh there you go okay yeah so
uh how did how did you get through
debt-free tell us your story so on you
know this is something that I do take a
lot of pride in because of the process
that I did have to go through to get
through college debt-free I started out
my first semester and my parents helped
me out with that first semester but I
remember when I made the decision to get
married after that first semester my dad
basically said if you can make that kind
of a decision then you're on your own
and I'll tell you what that was probably
one of the best things that ever
happened to me because then I had to
figure out I knew that I was going to go
through college that was not an option
for me but kind of like Rachel was
talking about earlier I was not going to
do it with debt so I was going to figure
out another way to get it done and so
once I once I was married I decided I
had to find a full-time job and it
couldn't be something that was just
going to be you know a minimum-wage type
job and I ended up working a full-time
job the entire time I went through
school forty hours a week at a straight
Commission job which for me was really
good it allowed me to make enough money
to make those payments for school and by
the time I graduated I was married we
had fun baby and we had one on the way
and you know with with working full-time
and and some of those grants and things
I would take any of the free money they
would give me and it's funny because I
did get some of those applications and
we had to dig through to figure out what
was the free money and what was a loan
and really you know focus take the time
to figure out what that was so that we
could stay away from getting into debt
but by going through all those Dody what
are you do now is it what's up what do
you do now and now I'm in pharmaceutical
sales okay
what's your income now I make anywhere
from 120 to 140 thousand dollars a year
what was your GPA when you graduated and
my overall was 385 my major GPA was a
four OH
what was how expensive a school was that
you went to um you know it's it's hard
to say how much it was per year that's
that's a good question I mean we my wife
and I wasn't more than a state school
less than a state school more than
Harvard less than Harvard
the state school tuition okay there was
not very expensive but okay I you know
I've never been you were showing strong
attention when you were selling straight
Commission in college what were you
selling selling furniture ah very cool
hey many hours a week great job Matt
thank you Matt congratulations you're it
man again it the the success of doing
this led to success an adult to it why
because it develops grit more than just
books since there's a pattern here you
guys seeing this this is the Dave Ramsey
show
Oh